yeah hey a new king is it down please
cuz I'm having a really hard time
whatever
yeah
sure man oh the sir right doctor thank
you how's it going everybody it's worn
and the hypervenom 2 has officially
begun
there has a lot that has been revealed
about this upcoming venom sequel
including new villains the release date
of course the Spider Man Disney Sony
deal has affected it as well and today
we have a pretty big plot leaked
concerning the film 1 of course
involving venom and Eddie Brock carnage
who was set up at the end of the last
venom movie shriek and spider-man so
I'll break down this fool plot leak and
after of course I'll talk about
everything that we know so far about
venom 2 including its release date and
all of the characters that are returning
and new ones that are going to be
introduced I'm still doing my Xbox one
and ps4 giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be subscribed to my channel
like the video and leave a comment down
below with your favorite superhero or
villain so of course a disclaimer about
this leak as always take it with a grain
of salt
this leak comes from 4chan and reddit so
this leak starts off by saying that
carnage is going to be the main villain
of the movie of course carnage was set
up at the end of venom 2 but it was
still unclear whether or not he was
going to be the main villain of venom 2
or perhaps venema 3 but according to
this leak
carnage is indeed going to be the main
villain of venom 2 and is going to be
made by the government they create
carnage from a sample of venom this is
an interesting way to introduce carnage
because many people were wondering how
this was going to happen exactly because
carnage is the offspring of venom and
based off of the way that everything
happened in the first venom movie it was
unclear of how exactly venom was going
to have an offspring and having the
government create carnage from venom
sample makes sense because it's kind of
like an offspring as well and this will
keep the same vibe that the first venom
had with the whole science lab and the
experiments being done on the symbiotes
the person that leaked this goes on to
say I don't know how Cletus Kasady comes
into contact with it but it is a mutant
that can multiply to infect other people
and a cassadee's master plan is to
spread it through the world now Cletus
Kasady is of course Woody Harrelson who
we saw at the end of venom one in the
comics Cletus Kasady is
host of carnage and we know from the end
of the first venom movie that Cletus
Kasady plans on escaping his holding
cell that he's in and wreaking havoc on
the world because he says that when he
gets out there will be carnage so
clearly at some point in time he's going
to break out of his holding facility and
come into contact with the symbiote
carnage and from there he's going to
multiply the symbiote and spread it all
over the world the leak says that Cletus
Kasady is going to have two cronies or
henchmen one is going to be his lover /
accomplice
Francis Barisan who is infected and
becomes a she carnage and the other is
going to be Malcolm McBride a scientist
involved in Carnage's creation who
Cassidy forces to work for him now for
those of you who do not know Francis
bearson is actually the character shriek
and shriek is actually a mutant now we
heard from another plot leaked not too
long ago that shriek is going to be one
of the other main villains in this film
during the maximum carnage story carnage
actually brakes shriek out of a holding
facility and from there on shriek
decides to follow carnage and actually
falls in love with him the two of them
end up recruiting other people to join
them in wreak havoc on the world and
they sort of act like the parents to all
of these other villains so it makes
perfect sense that she's going to be in
venom 2 with carnage as the main villain
and her being his love interest it also
seems like they could be prepping people
to prepare for the mutants to enter
because as it says in this plot leaked
carnage is actually viewed to be a
mutant as well so according to this plot
leak the two main villains of venom 2
are going to be mutants clearly they are
not going to be the same as the x-men in
Marvel Studios would not let them
introduce mutants and to the venom verse
before they introduce them into the MCU
so it's probably going to be like a
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver type of
introduction where they don't actually
call them mutants or x-men the leak
actually says that Naomi Harris is going
to be playing Francis no one has been
casted for MacBride yet but there's a
rumor going around that Shea Whigham is
circling the roll
captain Jean de Wolfe is in the script
too and she pursues venom after he is
framed for Carnage's crimes now what is
really interesting about having this
character in this film
if this leak ends up being true is that
Jean dewolff is largely associated not
with venom and carnage but with
spider-man and the Avengers so it seems
like the universes are starting to get
closer and closer together especially
after the Disney Sony deal and I'll talk
about this more in a few minutes when
this leak goes over
spider-man right now it says that latina
actresses are wanted for the role in
rosario Dawson is at the top of the list
Kevin Dunne is also in final talks to
play Eddie's new boss at the newspaper
aside from Tom Hardy Michelle Williams
and Woody Harrelson read Scott is also
coming back from the first movie as
Ann's doctor boyfriend but carnage will
kill him
it can't be carnage unless there is
actual carnage we had heads being bitten
off in the first movie by venom and
carnage is supposed to be even more
powerful and even more radical so we
know that there is definitely going to
be some violence in this movie a lot of
fans have been waiting for carnage for a
very long time and it definitely has to
be done right it goes on to say that
Anne will bond with venom again for a
she venom versus she carnage fight this
doesn't seem too far out there as we did
see in venom and bond with the Venom
symbiote becoming she venom and if
Francis Barisan or shriek is going to be
infected and become she carnage it would
make sense that she would fight she
venom especially if carnage ends up
killing her boyfriend
it also says that venom and carnage will
fight several times and the final fight
will take place at a hospital now venom
was a wildly successful movie it was
really good but it wasn't perfect and
one of the biggest complaints is that we
really didn't get enough action the
movie was rather slow to build up and
then when it finally did build up to the
action it seemed like it was over and
done in just a second it was a pretty
quick fight between riot and venom at
the end of the movie which was probably
one of the more disappointing facts
about the film even though it still was
very good but this league says that
carnage and venom are going to fight
several times which would definitely
make up for the lack of fighting in
venom especially since carnage is
supposed to be absolutely brutal and
carnage is going to have shriek with him
so that means venom is going to be
really underpowered here and that's when
you think that he would need the help of
spider-man now recently there has
definitely been a lot of teasing about
venom appearing in a spider-man film in
the MCU or spider-man appearing in venom
especially since Sony and Disney came to
an agreement and spider-man is remaining
in the MCU and if we don't really know
what the terms of the contract were
perhaps there were terms that said
spider-man gets to appear in the venom
verse or venom gets to appear in the MCU
but this leak does go on to say that
Sony is already planning a third venom
movie that is going to features
man and Sony wants spider-man to make a
cameo in venom too to set it up for
venom 3 now in this leak it already
mentions a way that venom slash Eddie
Brock and Peter Parker spider-man could
be connected and that part is where it
mentions that venom is going to be
blamed for the crimes of carnage does
that sound kind of familiar to you yes
it sounds exactly what happened at the
end of spider-man far from home if you
haven't seen spider-man far from home
spoiler alert but we learned that
Mysterio of course was not actually a
hero just like in the comics he was
pretending to be a hero but he was
actually the villain he was responsible
for creating the elementals and was
responsible for all of the destruction
that they did putting many people at
danger and at the end of the movie not
only did he reveal spider-man to be
Peter Parker but he also framed him for
all of the crimes that he committed
so Spiderman was framed in spider-man
far from home and in venom to supposedly
venom is going to be framed for all of
the crimes that carnage does so there's
your connection right there because we
know that Peter Parker is definitely
going to need some help and Eddie Brock
is a reporter he can help Peter Parker
if he clears his own name first and
Eddie Brock and venom are definitely
going to be over their head with carnage
and shriek and according to this leak
it's not going to be just carnage it's
pretty much going to be an army of
different Carnage's and again carnage is
way stronger than venom in the comics
and if they're going to stick with that
he's going to need a lot more help than
just she venom not to mention she venom
can't really fight at the same time as
venom because they are actually one
symbiote so venom is desperately going
to need the help of spider-man as well
and that of course is what everybody
wants to see we want to see venom
carnage and spider-man in one film and
the connection is there to do that which
of course is why this leak says that Tom
Hollands spider-man will make a cameo in
venom 2 now I've stated this many
different times before but originally
spider-man was supposed to make a cameo
in venom but Marvel Studios didn't allow
it because they didn't want people to
think that venom existed in the MCU
which of course is understandable but we
do know that Sony and Marvel have
recently struck up a new deal spider-man
is remaining in the MCU and perhaps some
of the terms of that contract are he
needs to cameo in the next venom film
and appear in venom 3 as well it makes
perfect sense but of course we're going
to have to wait and see until the film
actually comes out to see if this leak
comes to fruition now this leak does say
it's going to be rated PG
13 which isn't really much of a surprise
because the first venom film was rated
pg-13 as well despite many people
wanting it to be rated R but even though
it was pg-13 we still got to see some
heads being bitten off in the movie so
all is well
right now venom 2 is speculated to be
coming out on October 2nd of 2020 and
the reason we believe that the movie is
going to be coming out on that day is
that Sony has this slot listed on that
date and is titled untitled Sony /
Marvel sequel so of course it just makes
sense that they're referring to the
venom sequel and not to mention the
first venom movie came out in October as
well so why change it up but let me know
what you think about the details of this
leak would you like to see a she carnage
versus she venom fight and if you could
take anything from the first venom movie
and improve it in the second venom film
what would you do would you put more
action would you put different
characters in it let me know in the
comments down below also don't forget to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
venom 2 and of course the MCU
also don't forget to give the video a
like and comment down below so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win at
Xbox one or a ps4 I'll be starting a
giveaway on Twitter and Instagram really
soon as well so you can follow me on
there if you want to and of course as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof